- This is good for when you drive.
Driving with one hand,
eating your burrito with the other.
No?
(upbeat music)
We eat pizza in LA, we
just put salad on it.
That works, that works.
It's like salad and breadsticks had a baby
and then formed a pizza 'cause it doesn't
really taste like pizza.
It tastes more like salad and bread.
We're in downtown LA at Ramen Hood
where I'm about to eat a
vegan Ramen with a vegan egg.
As in laid by a tofurkey, not a chicken.
So the white part is made of soy milk
and the yellow part is nutritional yeast.
I guess you can't poke the yolk
to have it spill out.
Now for the ramen part.
The important part to ramen
is obviously the noodles
but more importantly is the broth.
Oh yeah.
Here's a delicious hot dog.
It's a carrot hot dog.
A hot dog made from carrots.
See, underneath all the brussels sprouts,
that's a carrot.
Uh, OK, gotta do the side bite.
It tastes like the carrots that would be
at the bottom of a stew,
something that's been cooked
for a really long time.
It does not taste like a hot dog at all,
but it's a fun way to eat your vegetables.
We're at Kye's in Santa Monica where
I just got a sushi burrito.
Let's go to the car and eat it.
Look at this thing.
Behold, the sushi burrito.
It's everything that you
would find in a burrito
except in a nori wrapper.
There's pinto beans and corn
and tortilla chips.
If you don't like seaweed,
you're not gonna like this,
but it's really delicious.
Tastes exactly like a burrito
except without a flour tortilla.
Thumbs up.
So this is organic ice cream.
Very important that it's organic,
has raspberry sauce, it
has chocolate crumbles,
chocolate shavings, and on top salted
caramel cotton candy.
I don't even know how to eat this.
My mouth doesn't know what to make
of this much sugar.
It's like everything my mom told me
not to do in one bite.
So if I had to crown the most LA food
for this video I think it
would probably have to be
the sushi burrito just because LA's known
for sushi and LA's known for burritos
and that was a perfect mashup.
Plus it was gluten free and vegan
and all that other stuff.